hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast and I'm checking in on you
Jesus Christ
just dropped my kid off right at school
and my wife's car the [__] thing
starts making this this noise
making this noise so I'm like
all right car of the future what the
[__] does that mean
is the door open I open the door I close
it
I open all the [__] doors I close
them
I [__] stop I shut the car off it's
still doing it I literally get it into
the driveway I shut it off I lock the
[__] doors and it's just sitting
there making that [__] noise inside
the car
[__] you [__] you [__] you [__] you I
went into settings
you know that was that was an expression
that didn't exist when I was a kid I was
around before personal computers
foreign
and I could tell you in my adult life
one of the saddest things
saddest new expressions
is or or or instructions if you go into
your settings
okay can you can you open up your
settings can you go into settings
like how much of your life involves that
being on the phone
with some [__] lonely nerd in the
middle of nowhere sitting on a phone
okay could you go in a second you know
what operating system you have
do I do no I don't know what operating
system I have
and then they get like upset with you
it's like dude I'm sorry computers
aren't my life my life is my life
I go out and do [__]
I'm gonna crawl inside this [__]
computer I appreciate that you know it
I hate when they do it you know what
your operating system is when you don't
they get like all upset and it's just
like hey do you know what a setup is
you know
do you know what a callback is am I
gonna get into the intricacies of
[__] comedy
and when you don't know it I'm gonna is
that really intricate bill you know what
I mean whatever the [__] it is that I do
I guess I don't have a hard job
I love how I just started talking about
myself like I was a doctor
um
all right whatever
what are you gonna do uh um how about
that Bruins game last night Bruins
Panthers game as much as it was a
heartbreaker
uh what a [__] great game just
quality playoff hockey the entire game
and um
I'm just not I'm not gonna watch any any
analysis
of uh my Bruins this playoffs because I
know it's all going to be like they have
the greatest record in modern regular
season history
why don't they would ever get you know
when they do that [__] it's like well I
mean their record is three and two now
so
I don't understand it every year the per
the team that wins the president's
trophy wins this daily oh wait they
don't
every time somebody has the greatest
record of regular season history anytime
that's happened they they've won and
that they've underst
it hasn't
it actually means if you're going to
look at that like it's a [__] stat
that matters in the playoffs which it
doesn't
um
you would actually say oh they did that
they're not going to win it
but what it is is you have these [__]
fat Tommy Bahama shirt wearing sports
writers and what they do
their job is to just hype [__] through
the [__] roof to get you excited and
then when it doesn't have they ignore
history so I'm not buying into any of
that all right we had an unbelievable
regular season and guess what that means
in the playoffs it doesn't mean [__]
because immediately they reset the
odometer and everybody's zero and zero
and when we win this series which I
think we will actually think we're going
to win game six
um
our records four and two in the playoffs
and then guess what we go to the next
round and it's zero and zero again
so
um I really wish there was just somebody
on network television or somebody in the
newspaper who just would have the
[__]
there's no way they don't know this
you know what I mean
I mean how many times can you watch this
happen
so
um
I actually going into the playoffs
didn't think the Bruins were the
favorite I just I think they're bigger
and faster in the West
you know Edmonton and Colorado dude the
Seattle Kraken are [__] a pain in the
ass team
to have to to win four out of seven
forget about just going into their
building and playing one game and being
like toodaloo
like you do in the regular season anyway
uh I thought it was um
I just thought it was a [__] it was a
great hockey game
um despite my son yelling at me because
he wanted to watch fire engines and like
that because that's what I always do the
whole the whole regular season I would
just be all right I watched the game
later which I would never do because by
then I would fall asleep
um
but uh now it's the playoffs
so now rather than being the new age dad
of like okay son if that's what you want
to watch Dad will shut off his program
I'm now in 19 you know 70s dead
you know it's the playoffs son all right
see that team at the B on their Jersey I
refuse to call it a sweater it's not a
sweater hasn't been a sweater since the
1930s
um root for that team hopefully I don't
even say that because I don't wanna
have a contrarian
start rooting for somebody else but um
in the Celtics I missed that game too
this is the new me remember the old me
on the podcast I saw every game
uh this is the new me Bill with kids
spill with kids misses games but he
knows what's going on as far as the the
uh the results at least
um that [__] Trey young Jesus Christ
I I gotta watch the end of that game you
know as much as I hate that he he beat
my team you gotta
you gotta love watching greatness though
um my father-in-law was telling me
saying uh we had the game one and he
just [__] took over the game
um
which obviously I don't like to see when
it happens to Celtics but as a fan of
sports
you know I love seeing somebody take
over a [__] game
you know
he lived vicariously through him like
yeah that's what I would do no bill
that's not what you'd do don't you
remember
gym class
wouldn't it be great if they actually
had your all-time stats from gym class
[Laughter]
If people could look them up so when you
were in a bar
you know gym class or if you played
organized Sports
um
at the high school level you know when
you were talking [__] about everything
you did someone could actually Google
you I bet in the future you'll be able
to do that
yeah it says here in uh dodgeball yeah
you know you never got you never got
past the top 16. so I don't think he got
such a strong arm you don't think you're
that [__] fast
do they don't play dodgeball anymore do
they I actually think that's one that's
a good thing
um I'll tell you what's embarrassing is
watching all the older Generations
acting like uh
I saw something the other day right
I'm also guilty of this but I don't take
it to this level
there was something about like the 1970s
and somebody wrote yeah back in this
yeah because back in the 70s no one
complained laughs
and someone goes that's right because
then your parents would say I'll give
you something to complain about
they would say I'll give you something
to complain about because you were
complaining
people have been complaining
back in the gay bad days
I wonder if the women if they you know
because they could drag them around by
their hair if they wouldn't [__] about
the cave this is the biggest cave you
could find
um all right anyway uh plowing ahead
here I had a uh
I had a I had a great day yesterday
but uh last night not so great not so
great my son has been just getting out
of the crib now and uh
not only can he get out he can get back
in again
okay the little man has grip strength
and he'll he will do a a pull-up into a
muscle up and go right up and over
um
so he just keeps getting out
you know all day and night and uh
I don't know what to do about it because
I'm not gonna yell at him
I'll mutter when I come down the hall
but I'm I'm not I'm not doing that
yelling thing so I just like
I heard his door open two nights ago at
like I don't know like [__] midnight
and I get up
and I go down the hall he keeps going
into his daughter's his daughter my
daughter's room
so oh no I was downstairs that's right
so I went upstairs I saw his door was
open and the light was out so I first
went to my daughter's room
he wasn't in there so that I went down
the hall
to our bedroom
and he wasn't in there and I'm like what
the [__]
so I opened the door
to his bedroom it's pitch black I turn
the light and he's standing like three
feet away from me staring up at me like
a [__] horror movie
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm like buddy
he's like yeah I'm like you got to go
back to bed and he goes yeah
and I
put him in bed
and um
the only way I can get him to stay there
is we have a an adult sized bed in there
and eventually I just have to stay in
there
which is stupid because now he wants me
to be in there
that's what I created it's supposed to
be so [__] tired I am so
I'm laying in the bed
and the other night he gets out like
last night he got out
I just heard I was just too tired to put
him back in the bed and I was just like
buddy come on
get in the bed so he gets in the bed
with me I don't know if this is like two
in the morning and for the next I don't
even know how how long 90 minutes
he won't stop squirming
you know
like laying on my head
kicking me like
grabbing on to me and he's like a little
hot water bottle you know
um
and then I don't know what happened he
finally went to sleep in his he was like
right in my ear snoring
yeah so he's right in my ear and he's
he's
snoring
and now I can't move because I'm so
worried that like if I move I'm gonna
wake him up and then I'm gonna have
another 90 minutes of him squirming
around and [__]
and uh
I don't know then I fell asleep and I
woke up this morning I could just hear
him breathing like a little dog in my
ear and I kind of pulled my head to the
side and I looked and he looked so
freaking cute
just 100 passed out so I was able to
kind of slip out of the bed
and get out of there
go downstairs and make my daughter
French toast before I took her to school
and of course I didn't use the right
bread
you know
and she's like Dad
I'm like what
I told you not to use the bread with the
sesame seeds on it and it's just like
all right
you know I actually did I just I didn't
I didn't say anything I just went over
and she had separated him I just took
them I put them in a little bowl
and she kept bitching at me and I just
didn't say anything I was just looking
at her just listening
and it's funny because that's works with
her mom too
when she really just starts laying into
me and I just don't feel like fighting
and I don't give a [__]
you know
I just go all right
that always it always works
I don't know why
if you if you engage with them they're
just like
you're just in for it you're in for a
[__] long
down drag it out and it's just it's not
going to get anywhere it's just going to
ruin a day
so I feel good about that like the last
two times
I was going to get into my wife in the
last two times I was you know my
daughter was like you know
coming at me I just kind of sit there
and look at them like all right
okay
continue on with this one-sided War oh
my God I apologize for this podcast I am
so [__] wiped out last night I got
like I feel like I got like two hours
sleep
um
but anyway I had a great day yesterday
oh I didn't even tell you guys I didn't
even tell you this guess what my [__]
Ford F-250 came on Monday
came on Monday it is absolutely [__]
gorgeous it's the best looking F250 I've
ever seen in like modern times
modern times meaning the last few like
Generations or whatever
it's [__] gorgeous and I got it and I
was like immediately I had this giant
wave of Catholic guilt oh like why did I
buy this I didn't need this thing I
don't deserve this thing this is still
all this type of [__] and that lasted
for about 40 minutes and
now I gotta tell you something
I I come out of the house every morning
and I look at that truck and I break
into a [__] ear to ear grin
I absolutely [__] love it and
I've already had problems out here with
it you know finding a place to park
going into a parking garage and it's too
high up and I don't give a [__] I just
park in a Red Zone I put the hazards on
I'll take the [__] ticket I don't
give a [__]
I cannot [__] believe I own that
truck
6.7 liter turbo diesel
sounds like a [__] train coming down
the street oh really it sounds like an
18-wheeler it's it's one of the greatest
sounds I've ever heard in my life it has
two three pronged outlets in the bed LED
lights
um in the bed it's got a three-pronged
outlet
in in the cab to 12 volts and then it's
got two different uh things for like
your [__] iPhone or your iPad
um
I got the towing package the whole thing
and somebody goes oh that's awesome
because I sent a picture and you know
most people don't understand why
somebody would like a truck
you know
and then just like uh
somebody said to me
oh that's great now you can help
everybody move and I just wrote back how
dare you
she's too pretty to work
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my God it is absolutely [__]
gorgeous it's absolutely I'd send I
would post pictures of it if there
weren't so many [__] psychos out
there
um
but anyway uh
so yesterday
uh my buddy Josh Adam Meyers was in town
from the goddamn Comedy Jam and uh in
the Billy Joel Stevie Nicks
concert uh
or as I call a mosh Adam gyre's
he's in town and I've always been
telling him like dude I'm gonna I want
to take you up in the helicopter and
he's like yeah let's do it so yesterday
I said hey man I got a new truck let's
go [__] drive up and I'll take you up
in the uh in the helicopter
took him up in the truck
he loved the truck
uh and we would just laughing and I was
just driving down the street cone do you
realize how ridiculous ridiculous it is
that I have this truck
like me is happy for me she goes Jesus
Christ she goes what are we starting a
construction company
and I couldn't I couldn't argue I was
like I know
I know she goes well I'm happy for you I
said all right thanks so uh anyway we
get in the thing and I'm driving down
the highway
you know I'm talking to Josh and I said
this is how I look at it if some jerk
all these jerk offs out here can buy
Ferraris
and sit and stop and go traffic and not
take ever take the car to the track can
I drive a Ford F250 four-wheel drive
with the [__]
towing package
why can't I do that and never go
four-wheeling I'm not saying I'll never
do that
um I might take it out to the desert
um
but anyway we drove up in the truck
all right
and uh
you know pre-flighted the helicopter
cleaned it up a little bit had a bunch
of bugs on it from last time and uh
gassed her up and everything and we took
off it was funny when we took off I
heard Josh go
they had to make that noise it's a real
weird sensation like uh hovering and
then just going to take off and uh and
sitting up front the first time I
remember feeling that the first time I
went up with an instructor
and um
but once we got up there he was like oh
he's like yo this is amazing and we just
like flew all around unfortunately it
was a really
smoggy day there wasn't a lot of wind or
anything like that so I wasn't able to
take him up the coast of Malibu but it
was something I've been wanting to do
for a while so I took him around the
Rose Bowl Dodger Stadium downtown L.A
Griffith Park Observatory Hollywood Sign
Capitol Records
write down Sunset Strip past Laugh
Factory Comedy Store and then there's a
couple there's like the Doheny Mansion
The Godfather mansion
Beverly Hills Hotel
and then that mansion that that guy did
that documentary on called the one that
they wanted to sell for 500 million
dollars or some [__] like that I took
him over that and then we got over to um
what is that out there I guess it's is
that Brentwood over like Brentwood and
then you could just see the Marine layer
and I was just like yeah
I don't want to deal with that I mean I
guess I could have went underneath it it
wasn't that
I'd have to I don't know then I have to
just turn around and come back I just
didn't want to [__] and it was super
hazy and there was a marine layer and
I'm like what was he really going to see
here but anyway then uh I brought him
back
landed and all that type of [__] and uh
came back we hit a diner
both got BLTs and a cappuccino
and then we smoked a cigar it was like
the greatest like this little cigar on
on my back porch
and I was saying to him I was like dude
how [__] great was this day
it's only [__]
you know three in the afternoon
so that was my day
um yeah
I was joking with my father-in-law when
I went with when the truck came I go all
right I go that's my midlife crisis and
he laughed and he goes could have been a
lot worse I'm like it could have could
have I could have
bought something you know lots a lot
dumber than that so
um oh Billy good mood I know I sound a
little low right now
I just didn't get a
I didn't get a lot of sleep but I will
tell you by the ninth time my son got
out of bed
I was Furious as far as like just being
grumpy and I when I started coming down
the hall
and uh I went in there
and I was immediately able to just
take that energy and bring it all the
way down I'm like come here buddy buddy
you can't do this and I'm really proud
of that as a debt that I'm able to do
that because I just don't want to ever
uh I don't I don't want to make my kids
like me
[Laughter]
like if you guys
heard the [__] rant I went on
when I was in my wife's car about how
[__] stupid some of these like all of
this new goddamn [__] technology is
like
these computers in these cars you're
gonna end up having the same [__]
problem you have with your laptop
we're like what what is going on you
can't figure it out and for the life of
me I don't understand like why did it
just out of curiosity why do they have
to be this complex
like what the [__] was wrong
I mean I look I understand for safety
purposes you know because if you want to
see something [__] up don't you know
go watch some of those videos of like
people back in the day getting in these
car accidents that today you would
survive
and they get pinned under the steering
wheel and burned to death I mean it was
just like or that's like hanging halfway
out the [__] windshield
and they have like all the graphic they
used to show those things um they didn't
do it to my generation they think they
did it right up to the 1960s and then
they were like what are we doing
um they would just show like the dead
bodies
are the fire departments showing up and
you just see this charred person sitting
there
and engulfed in flames
um so they I don't know where the happy
medium was
I mean I like the new technology with
the with the uh
the suspensions and stuff I guess it's
just what human beings do so we just
keep trying to make them better and
better and better it is I think it is
amazing that you can have
you know with the push of a button
different suspension options and I'm
sure there's got to be some sort of
computer [__] involved in that but um
I gotta tell you man my wife's car Jesus
Christ he's got one of those Teslas
um fast as [__]
never have to get gas and stuff like
that but like
um it definitely brings you into uh
it's like driving a laptop
so
I'm on the fence with those things I
love that they don't use gas I do love
that because in my simplistic view of
the world is if we had electric cars
you know we wouldn't be dependent on oil
in uh the Middle East as much and then
maybe we wouldn't be you know trying to
air quote bring them freedom and then
they would be mad at us because the way
we bring freedom is to drop bombs on
them
and then they'd want to come over here
and [__] us up like if we just sort of
use less of that maybe we just would
ignore that part of the world
and uh we wouldn't be you know involved
in that [__] because it bankrupted this
company this company this country
which is something for some reason like
they'll never talk about
like us going over there in in Operation
Freedom whatever the hell they called it
you know it was initially Saddam was
part of 9 11 and then it was he has
weapons of mass destruction
and then it became it's a Liberation
they just kept changing why they were
going over there
and
um
for whatever reason people supported it
um which I think for most people it was
uh cheaper gas
and now here we are I drove down the
street the other day and it's like seven
something a gallon I saw
and uh so you know what that means
people will be like [__] Joe Biden
and they're gonna ignore and they never
really report on it every August
you know for some reason in August is
when the the check is due
and
there's this serious thing of like oh my
God is the dollar gonna collapse that
happens every year in August and their
solution is they print another trillion
dollars with nothing behind it which
just causes inflation
you know this giant [__] Ponzi scheme
and then whoever's in office gets blamed
liberals blame the conservatives
conservatives blame the Liberals and all
it is is just a bunch of constant suits
sitting in the Federal Reserve and for
the life of me I don't understand why
the standing president doesn't just send
one [__] platoon
from the Army down there and just walk
in and just say yeah uh you know we're
running this [__] now
we're taking this over like why can't
they do that they do that when they
build highways
and they just walk into little people's
houses right the little people going
yeah that said eminent domain [__] you
we're building a highway here why don't
we just do that to them walk in there
and be like hey guess what here's the
deal
you don't run this [__] anymore we do
and we don't owe you [__] and you should
be happy and we're not hanging you by
your [__] toes out in the goddamn
Town Square
I don't know why the [__] won't they do
that
what I think it is is because if they if
they did it the dollar would collapse
and there would be chaos for a minute
and all those [__]
horse that our politicians
you know like all the rest of us were
all bought into the Ponzi scheme so they
don't want to topple the Ponzi scheme
they're like they're just hoping it
doesn't topple within their lifetime
on like their watches the only way that
I can kind of
kind of see that I don't know
would have been nice you know Bernie
Sanders he wanted to go after those guys
he wanted to go after those guys you
know what they call them a communist
hahaha
so I've gotten to the point in my life
where I'm just like you know what [__]
it I'm just gonna sit back and see the
humor in how [__]
self-destructive we are as I go out and
buy a gas guzzling Ford F-250 that I
don't need
um how funny is that I'm sitting there I
like the electric cars that you know
it'll be great we'll be less dependent
on the Middle East and then I go out and
buy a [__] F250
I mean that's classic human behavior
right there right on this podcast you
know what we need to do while I'm doing
the exact opposite we need more people
to be like me
the hypocrite
um
so anyway uh that is the podcast uh
Florida Panthers
someone's telling me uh was who knows a
lot about hockey going like yeah that
terrible you guys are gonna beat them
you're gonna [__] like roll right
through them and I immediately was just
thinking like no we're not
we're not
it's the playoffs playoffs
the playoffs
it's a whole different [__] thing
so um
I wish I had something to promote right
now a project because they usually have
me go on these Sports shows
that'd be a fun thing to bring up
like what are you guys going to stop
acting like the regular season mean
something
or when are you gonna stop putting this
level of weight on the regular season
then I think other sports fans do it
because they want to help gas it up too
because then if your team doesn't win
they get to act look what a giant
failure that was
and those are the sports fans who I
think they don't even like sports
as much as they like to see
failure and live vicariously through
the success of other people meeting
their home team
and I will say those are the ones I
can't [__] talk to did that thing
break
oh no it didn't I gotta get rid of this
[__] thing I have so many goddamn
knickknacks over the years that people
have given it to me when I'm on the road
and I can't get rid of them because I
sit there and go like somebody like my
comedy so much that they actually made
this or they bought this they took the
time to give it to me and now I'm like
drowning in this [__]
so
some of this stuff I I do I do have to
get rid of why don't you put in the back
of that truck you didn't need bill
all right take it easy huh
I swear if I didn't have kids I would
sell my Jaguar
I can't believe I'm saying that because
I love that [__] cartoon but that's
it I would get rid of it
I'll get rid of it a second I would use
that other one as my daily driver
um anyways that is the podcast I
apologize for the the low energy I will
make it up to you on Monday and for
those of you who came out to the uh
uh the live podcast or who uh watched it
I want to thank you for that and uh
I gotta watch a clip of that man because
I'm not gonna lie to you I went out
there and I was [__] Oh Billy Bill
Billy boy was on
and uh there's something I did this rant
about going to the [__] Universal
Studio
theme park that I want to watch because
um
there's a couple of things that I did in
there and I sang some song
about the homeless that somehow involved
paddle shifters on your car and I can't
remember how it went but it ended up
rhyming or it went perfectly it was just
one of those perfect [__]
it was almost like a set
um and I'm thinking of doing some more
of those
you know uh
just got to figure that out all right
sorry half asleep here all right that is
the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast have a great weekend you can't
and I'll talk to you on Monday
[Music]
okay what's going on uh yeah
we're doing
um it's Bill Burrs Monday Morning
podcast and I literally literally have
just woken up and decided that I have to
do this [__] thing because I gotta go
I gotta jump back on the bus
jump back on the bus heading over to uh
Jackson Mississippi
you know I'm nervous about Mississippi
you know what I mean this is the one
state that scares other Southern States
you know
they just it's like the Texas of the
South
it's like
um
it's like the Ted Kennedy of the
Kennedys
was another good example
you know it's like the uh it's like the
kiwi or the Birds
it's just this little [__] State
without wings you know
everybody's just hoping
just hoping one day it's gonna Sprout
its [__] wings and something's gonna
happen I can be honest with you I don't
know [__] about Mississippi
you know what I mean although last night
in Huntsville Alabama
Huntsville Huntsville Alabama
you know everybody around here calls it
cuntsville you know they do of course
they do
because what do you do you don't you
don't like the town next to you
our Town's better than your town we have
the exact same [__] trees and there's
an invisible line but our our trees are
better right nobody likes nobody
everybody makes fun of the town next to
him
everybody makes fun of the state next to
them everybody makes fun of the country
next to them it just keeps going and
going and going and they say hey our
continent's better than your continent I
like our ocean better than your ocean
right next thing you know
he's shooting a couple of missiles
um
some on stage here in Huntsville you
know what kills me was we were here for
a day and a half and we got in the night
before
and uh the same place that I performed
at DJ Fontana was there the night before
I swear to God I know a lot of you
youngsters are going like oh Mike who's
DJ Fontana
no not that kind of DJ
he backed up he was Elvis's drummer
the real Elvis not the impersonator
um in case you didn't know Elvis was
I guess now he does like an Elvis
tribute thing and a lot of you guys are
probably thinking that's [__] sad
well what's he supposed to do what are
you supposed to do when you're a drummer
and the guy that you back up
[__] dies at 42. what are you gonna
do I mean you're gonna live for another
30 [__] years you need some money
right will you go [__] something
you're gonna do it just find some guy
that can do an impersonation of him
it's a tough gig being a drummer there's
very few of them that when the [__]
lead singer either tells him to [__] off
you know or they die usually the drummer
is [__] the lead guitarists can
somehow come up with the band
like I'm trying to think uh
you know I would say Dave Grohl
Dave Grohl's the only guy I ever seen
come out of that thing
you know
and go on be on top and actually be as
big as his other band was none of those
a lot of Nirvana fans no one will ever
Eclipse Nirvana
Nirvana put hair metal
down where it belonged
let me just
they just made these songs and they
start off loud and they were quiet and
they were loud and they were quiet and
they were loud and then they were loud
and then that was it that was the song
um
I don't know what the [__] I'm talking
about I'm babbling here as always so
anyways DJ Fontaine was there I could
have gone I could yeah I could have met
the guy I don't know if I could have met
the guy but uh [__] kills me I could
at least see him play
yeah
a little bit nice
so anyways I'm on stage last night in
Huntsville Alabama
and um
I I mentioned that I didn't believe in
God
and it got really kind of quiet and
whatever and I was just like come on guy
you know I'm not drinking I'm just I
just think I'm fertilizer when I'm dead
I just go on the ground and that's my
job I think that's a beautiful thing I
go into the ground and I make the soil
richer right or maybe I become a fossil
fuel
for the next [__] thing that takes
over the planet and then doesn't like
the town next to him and doesn't like
the state and so on and so forth right
so I mean the crowd yells uh
better not say that Mississippi
[Music]
[Laughter]
God that was the creepiest thing I think
anybody's ever said better not say
not sick then somebody had Jake gyles
[__] queued up my blood runs cold
cold I don't know I'm looking forward to
going at believe it or not I'm looking
forward to going to Mississippi I'm
looking forward to interacting with
those people and I'm looking forward to
like uh you know making a couple
stereotypes go away although I know
there's going to be a lot that will
reinforce it
you know I know there's going to be a
lot of stay on the main highways
get off at like a Burger King and then
get the [__] back on the bus and get out
of here I know there might be elements
of that but you know
I did look up some comedy clubs and I
started to see who was playing there
and uh this is tour that's going around
called The Standing Ovation tour that
stars some more some more uh Tony Rock
did a couple of dates Arnez J one of the
funniest Comics ever
and um
you know they all came through here
I think they did already I don't know so
I figured right they came down here they
had a good time Corey hulkman came down
here
um
it's weird you would think that that
would just be white Comics coming down
here with Mississippi's [__]
reputation you know all I found was as
far as Comics said I knew they were all
black
so anyways we'll see what happens
to Old freckles I think it'll be fun I
just don't need somebody with a [__]
hardcore southern accent
the one uh
they're talking about the [__] don't say
that Mississippi
I uh I had another guy last night I'm
getting deep in the South right now is
what's going on because last time I
talked to you guys I think I was just
rolling into Memphis
and um
you know since then we did Shreveport
then we did New Orleans
and uh it was all good huntsville's the
first time I was just like wow I'm
really in the South here just with a
couple of heckles because I was talking
about how you know oh I love SEC
football and how I wanted to uh come
through and go to Alabama game
in Auburn game and I would love to go to
the Alabama Auburn game but it's you
know it's Thanksgiving weekend every
year and there's no [__] way
you know you can ever make that game
unless you live in Alabama you can't
leave your wife you know your wife and
family you just can't do it
[__] carve up the turkey
you know give thanks and then jump on a
[__] red eye to Alabama which is what
I would have to do
um although it is a Saturday game I
might be able to get away with that
I might be able to get away with that
but anyways
so I was just talking about uh I was
saying how I like both teams I was very
being very impartial and I was
everybody's like War Eagle Roll Tide
screaming it was [__] awesome and
somehow I started talking about how
[__] badass it is
I say come on
Bama fans you got to admit that [__]
eagle flying down from the top of the
stadium right onto uh the guy's arm you
gotta admit that's the [__]
you gotta admit that's the [__] some
Alabama fam said my favorite thing was
when the eagle flew into the glass I
guess it went into like the luxury boxes
it just flew right into it
and they were laughing you know I like
animals and I go out give me a [__]
break it happened one goddamn time I go
sir how many [__]
play glass windows of you walking and
walked into in your life
and the guy was like none to have it
walked into Annie I go give me a [__]
break
I go when Auburn when Auburn returned
that field goal against Alabama you
probably walked through the side of your
house and the place went [__] nuts
Auburn fans
flipped out screaming and Bama fans are
like right and then when it all died
down somebody in the back yelled out go
back to Mississippi
laughs
that's just like in the crowd I went
right it was really very high school and
I was like wait I haven't been to
Mississippi yet
you know
and not only that I've been [__] on
your side sir
I brought him down
I've been on your side the whole [__]
show here I am talking about
you know equal pay
you know if you just make women make the
same amount of money as guys and you
don't change anything else it's not fair
it's just something I'm doing on my ACT
some you believe it or not that bit is
actually empowering to women
after I brow beat them you know it's a
fun job anyways so this is the Monday
Morning podcast I'd even say the date
yet for April 27th the last Monday
the last [__] Monday
in April in 2015 there'll never be
another Monday
in April 2015 you can say that you were
there
you were there you lived it
you enjoyed it you put your hands in
that soil and you felt it
um
so what are you gonna do huh how did you
do this month
how'd you do this month
you're a good husband were you a good
father well you were good mother
not even chowing down
been doing all right what do you need do
you need to Fat shame yourself check in
on yourself just checking in on you on
the last Monday
you know I actually had somebody come up
to me said geez bill I thought you're
gonna be a lot bigger I'm like what the
[__] I'm average height he's like no
fatter the way you [__] on yourself I
said dude I've been killing it at the
gym my friend
I go to the gym every day
it's just become about my life and if
you don't want to be a fade well you go
to the gym every day you can't
I said you'll go to that cookie gym
every day I keep saying every month you
go to the gym every day
um
so that made me feel all right and by
the way too all this fat shaming I've
been doing
making people fat shame themselves uh I
had a couple come up to me
and said that collectively they had lost
like 80 pounds
I had uh and then I've had like three or
four different people say one guy had
lost over a hundred pounds the other guy
lost 80. and I think there was a 60 in
there
so there you go
you watch that [__] show The Biggest
Loser where they're screaming in your
face save money scream in your own face
go into the [__] bathroom take off
your goddamn shirt
see where you sit right
see where you're at
in the rankings
be honest about what your torso is
looking at and just look yourself in the
mirror huh
browbeat yourself
and then you end on a positive note
right after you [__] what the [__] is
going on right then you bring it around
in the end
we're better than this
right we get one life we get one body
we're not [__] doing this and you
turn it around and all you got to do is
you just gotta break that [__] sugar
salt thing
when you wake up in the morning that
thing that's telling you to get an Egg
McMuffin that things are telling you to
eat [__] pancakes and all that [__]
you go no you know what shut the [__] up
you override it you override those
cravings and you go down and you just
you make yourself some [__] oatmeal
nothing in it you [__] slam that down
with the banana
throw some berries or some [__] like
that and then you [__] you level
yourself off what's that [__] they give
you
when you're trying to get off uh
heroin
better methadone I don't know what the
[__] it is
oatmeal
is the food version of that
it's the full version of that by the way
dude I I I don't follow a couple people
on uh Facebook
and uh they just said in all of these
[__] links to what the [__] they're
doing to our food supply minutes really
goddamn scare
it's really [__] scary
you know
I think that's how they're going to
solve the population problem because if
you're gonna [__] turn the food into
poison there you go if nobody's allowed
to say what is in the food
it's terrifying
[__] apples that don't turn brown
what is wrong with people
what the [__] is wrong with those
goddamn people that work on those those
corporations
well I you know
that type of that type of psycho [__]
you know you ever play like you pick up
hoop or pick up hockey
let me just feel you ever just play with
the sociopath you're not even playing
for anything you just feel it that
[__] person that's willing to do
anything
it's unreal
speaking of which
how about those Boston Celtics what a
great goddamn season I got to say that
first before we get into the negativity
of the game yesterday and God knows I
don't [__] watch the Celtics
you know
God knows I don't [__] well I I still
love him but you know you only got time
for so much right you're either a
[__] hoop guy oh you're a hockey guy
I don't know Joe Joe bartnick's the only
guy I know that can talk intelligently
and in depth about both I don't know how
the [__] he does it
um
but anyways the Celtics were in the
playoffs we made the seventh seed
basically don't have any stars it was a
hell of a coaching job by that guy that
everybody's saying is a great coaching
hire
can repeat what other people say but I
actually watched the game I've actually
watched Ben watching hoop because I'm on
tour here with uh lawhead and Versi and
um
you know it's just been uh you know I've
been watching some of this they've been
like good games I guess
but uh I watched the uh a lot of that
Celtics game yesterday hoping Celtic
Pride we at least wouldn't get swept
but um
I gotta tell you that [__] Kevin Love
inches his shoulder
you know and then he turns around and he
blames sweet innocent
beautiful flowing hippie hair
Nick have you say his name
how dare He suggests that that was a
dirty play now this you'll think that
this is that I'm not being impartial
here because I'm a Celtics fan okay the
ball goes up hits the rim
okay now for right out of the gate
right out of the gate it's already the
Cavalier's fault
because if that [__] jerk off who
took the shot hit the shot
there was no way that Kelly would have
been concerned about the left arm of of
Kevin Love
and felt the need to cradle it within
his body and then turned to the side and
spoon with him
had the Cavaliers
whoever the [__] it was
I mean you get LeBron why didn't you say
I'm going to dunk on everybody knob got
to take a shot had to get fancy
right rubbing it in
I'm just [__] with you um I don't
even I don't know anything about hoop
part of me wants to think that Kelly
stinks because he just looks like he
stinks
I don't know [__] about who but I look
at that guy and I look at like that's
not the guy I'm picking
um
I mean he just looked like one you know
like those spazes you play with who just
suck so they just they're always [__]
grabbing you
you know what it reminded me reminded me
when I was a kid
when me and my brother fell out of a
tree simultaneously because we were
trying to teach my other brother trying
to show my other brother who there's
this part of there was this tree we used
to climb up
and um
and you know the main trunk went up and
then it split
and as it went further up obviously the
Gap got greater and greater right just
like a horse legs
um
it was it was the horror tree
why couldn't the tree be giving birth
shut up lady
um
so we got up to a certain height and
there was no branches on one side one
side of the the trunk that went up until
you got to a certain height and the only
way to get over to the other side of the
tree was you had to swing across on this
dead branch
so my older brother swung across and
then I swung across and then my younger
brother wouldn't [__] do it
because it was a dead Branch because you
know he's like it's a dead Branch I'm
not doing it well like yeah but we weigh
more than you and we did it and he
wouldn't do it
so we go all right what if we both hang
on this [__] Branch together
and if it doesn't break then you'll do
it and he's like yeah
so we both go out and we hang on the
branch my brother's on the inside he
weighs more I'm on the outside we hang
on it it doesn't break we go all right
come on man let's go swing across the
branch
and he still wouldn't do he goes do it
one more time so this time I'm thinking
like well it's a [__] dead Branch I
want to get on the inside so I got on
the inside
my older brother got on the outside
but going see look it's safe it's
[__] safe crack and the thing just
snapped
so we went going down to the ground
and I'm coordinated my older brother is
not coordinated and I'm [__] getting
ready to land
somewhat in a way well I'll get hurt the
least and as my brother's going down
you know ass and back of the head first
he reaches out and grabs my shoulder
and pulls me into his uncoordinated
nightmare
we slam down on the ground
he got knocked out I didn't I remember
he got knocked out he was laying face
down in the [__] dirt
my other brothers were laughing thinking
he was [__] around
and my dad had just
happened to pull up he's like Christ you
know I'm not gonna name him so he goes
what's he what's he doing laying in the
dirt
he's like oh [__] Craig's sake he's
unconscious right
but I remember like he [__] reached
out and grabbed and said what the [__]
are you grabbing on me for
because he wasn't coordinated and that's
how I feel uh that Kelly the part of me
thinks that he stinks so bad
that that was actually him playing
basketball but my final verdict was it
was dirty because I just never see
anybody ever grab somebody's arm like
that
in basketball
and it was just weird like what are you
doing it was like he was carrying a
giant salami of some [__] and at the
last second he like [__] turned his
body
and I you know I'm gonna have to side
with Cavalier fans I think that was a
dirty [__] play
and um
you know
I don't know it was good to see Perkins
though
I don't know why we haven't [__]
traded that guy
you know I I
don't know maybe now I don't know about
hoop maybe it was a good [__]
movement when we traded him I didn't
think that that was a good move
but whatever congratulations to the
[__] Cavaliers
congratulations Celtics for a great uh a
great season but um I really hope that
wasn't a dirty play because that's the
number one thing that I [__] hate I
hate when you can't beat a team then you
just hurt their player and that just
really affects
the Cavaliers on the next level and just
fans in general you could have seen a
totally healthy [__] Cavalier team
take on uh well they play the Bucks of
the bulls look at me talking hoop here
um
and now one of the best guys is out you
want to [__] the whole season you
weren't gonna win anyways why would you
do that
I don't know I think it was uh I think
it was a dirty play
in fact it was so dirty I'm sure the
Pittsburgh Penguins are calling Kelly
Olynyk right now and asking me if he
could skate
hahaha
tell you now I'll tell you right now
Kelly that is Ring of Honor level stuff
here at the Pittsburgh Penguin
organization there's nothing we like
better than someone who's willing to
hurt somebody who's better than them on
another team during a deciding game in
the playoffs
um
that should be under the Pittsburgh
Penguin logo good Lord have they had
some of the worst most [__]
reprehensible human beings on their team
forever
um and they've had some great ones
I guess they're smart
it's like they they [__] draft the
Mario Lemieux and then they go all right
who's gonna try to end his career let's
get that guy too
let's just make sure this [__] piece
of [__] is blowing out knees on the
other team and not blowing out our knees
maybe maybe it's a [__] maybe maybe
it's an intelligent move I don't know I
don't pretend to know things
sure you do Bill your whole [__]
podcast is based on it I'll go [__]
yourself
um
anyways let's do a little reading out
loud shall we you guys ready for this
have you had your morning coffee
you [__] drug addicts I can't get my
dagos in my [__] cough you know
that's why I never drank coffee other
than the fact that it tastes like dirty
water
um
granted I never had it hot I used to
drink my dad's when he went to work I'd
take sips of it when it was [__]
Stone Cold
and uh you know that whole I'm gonna be
an adult and I'd sip it was [__]
disgusting I'm glad I never got into it
people can't start that day they just
sit there with their brown coffee
stained [__] teeth
you know how many hours of your life how
many days how many weeks or months are
your life are you gonna waste standing
in a line at Starbucks
every time I go to a [__] airport the
second they bring that thing up these
junkies are just standing there
you know like they're waiting for
Springsteen tickets so they can continue
chai latte with the [__]
[__] squirt of uh some whipped cream
chilling out there
you know with like a heroin Shake
um oh J pill you're just better than us
in that area I am all right
speaking of truck stops we actually
stopped at one
somewhere in [__] Alabama or
Mississippi when we were coming up from
uh
uh New Orleans do you know what it means
to Miss New Orleans that's where my baby
goes
she gives me a hand job she used
humidity for lubricants when she jerks
my dick in the middle of July
pulling it out of my Sia soccer suit
um put your damn dick away and keep it
moving
sorry
uh
yeah we stopped off at a truck stop and
uh you know I had to relieve myself not
once but twice if you know what I mean
and I go into this [__]
bathroom and there's some trucker
already in there in there dropping a
deuce and I'm already laughing my ass
off because I'm only one toilet away and
I'm on a bus what am I gonna do I gotta
go and I'm like am I Really Gonna Take a
Dump next to a [__] trucker in
Mississippi at a truck stop I gotta do
it and then all of a sudden like every
truck trucker from here to Tuscaloosa
[__] came in there and I had to leave
he's like I can't [__] do it and I
kept trying to walk in there you know
when there was nobody there there was
always five truckers and that original
trucker never moved he was just sitting
there
just I don't know [__] his brains
out or couldn't
oh my God he had these awful white
Seinfeld sneakers that were all [__]
creased up and dirty
dad jeans
it was one of the [__] low points of
my stand-up career although I was
laughing my ass off because verzie goes
in there and he comes back out and I
just started laughing he's just gonna do
it I can't I I can't I need I just I
can't
um
that's just [__] it's not all luxury
being on a tour bus just put it that way
but um oh I didn't mention you know a
lot of people gave me [__] because
whenever I go to these cool places I
never mention what they are because I
don't want to ruin them for the locals
but [__] it I'll switch that up you know
because people are going dude you don't
realize how arrogant you are that you
feel like you know you just mentioning
it on your podcast is going to ruin
those places all right so let's see
so we went to New Orleans
um New Orleans
and uh I played this amazing theater
that I could not pronounce
uh beginning with an s
and uh all I know is Bob Dylan was going
to be performing in the next week which
is a pretty big [__] thrill to be
performing on a stage that he performs
on not because that's what he's selling
these days he just loves this place so
much
um
and it was uh just an amazing [__]
show
and it's such a great time and then we
had a couple of days off
so the next night you know
hey this is the deal with New Orleans if
you go to New Orleans and you just go to
Bourbon Street if you're in your 20s
you'll probably enjoy it if you're in
your 30s or older you're going to be
like not only is this [__] an
absolute [__] show this is one of the
worst cities in the country it's dirty
it's evil it's dirty and evil whatever
sorry I needed a third one
um however if you get the [__] out of
there and you go you go north the
goddamn City whatever [__] Direction
it is
um you're going to see those beautiful
houses and you'll literally go from
going like this [__] place is awful
too wow I could live here
so we went to a place called uh
Commander's Palace
for some of the best seafood I've ever
[__] had
uh if you're going to New Orleans I'm
telling you right now take your wife
over there okay
well just shut the [__] up no sorry that
just for some reason was thinking Harvey
Keitel when you test you just take the
gun and smash it on the nose watch them
shut the [__] up
let's go get a taco
um
and then afterwards we wanted to go
smoke a cigar
and um you know it's like I knew some
cigar bars down around the French
quarter and I was like I don't want to
go down there
you know you go down there and it's just
a bunch of drunks
it's just it's like the Jerry Springer
Show You Know The Jerry Springer Show
just has the worst representation of
every race every demographic when you go
down to Bourbon Street that's what you
have you have the worst
from every state and then you have the
worst people in New Orleans hovering
around them trying to take advantage of
them in any way possible so
I was like there's got to be something
better so our waiter was the [__]
um and he told us about this place
called uh dos Jeff Ace dose like uh
Spanish for two homes
d-o-s-e and then Jeff j e f f e s
they had these great cigars
and then they had this live music that
we listened to oh did I already tell you
this I think I mentioned it on the
podcast last week
I'm sorry dude I don't even know where
the [__] I'm at right now
um
but we just had the best I'll even say
it again we had the best time best food
best place I've been to as far as where
to eat in New Orleans and uh just the
coolest [__] bar with this
unbelievable live music
and um
I'm telling you if you do that alone
you're [__] you'll want to go to New
Orleans every goddamn year
[Music]
um
so anyways
having said all of that
let's
congratulate everybody who got out of
the first round in the NHL playoffs
all right I don't know what's going on
with Detroit and Tampa Bay
I haven't been able to keep up with that
congratulations to the Minnesota Wild
you know
great series for you guys and my
condolences to St Louis Blues fans I
mean I don't know what the [__] you got
to do what are the St Louis Blues gotta
[__] do to get out of the first round
of the [__] playoffs
that was the team I was like this is the
guys I'm gonna root for these [__]
guys I thought they were going to make a
run
at least go a couple of series
[__] brutal
what did St Louis [__] blues fans do
to the hockey gods
they really are like the [__] Los
Angeles Clippers
of of hockey they're just never gonna
get out of the first round I don't know
[__] about who but I'll tell you right
now when the [__]
the Spurs won game two that series was
over it's over they're going to turn on
every [__] thing that they know about
how to win a championship and it's it's
going to be done because the Clippers
they don't have it I can say that
because I don't watch hoop
um so congratulations to them
congratulations to the Rangers
I know the Ducks won Calgary Flames
um
who else is out there that I'm
forgetting there's got to be one other
series oh the Blackhawks
the Blackhawks one so who do you like
out there Blackhawks Flames ducks
Minnesota I mean you got to go with the
experience right you got to go with the
Blackhawks even though they [__]
every [__] other period they got a
different guy in there Crawford than the
other guy then Crawford and the other
guy
then the other guy and then crawfordton
Crawford and then the other guy somehow
they made it work
somehow they made it work so um who am I
rooting for out there I'll root for the
Calgary Flames
I want to root for them because in 1989
they beat the Montreal Canadiens back
when the Bruins could never beat them
um so that was nice to watch so I've
always liked Calgary because of that
then Lanny McDonald they got the [__]
red-headed guy with the psycho mustache
come on dude he's [__] killing it guy
looked like he just stepped out of a
[__] mine shaft then he'd go in and
score a goddamn goal right
that he'd smile like it was Christmas
how could you not love that guy
right
um
it's been a lot of great [__] Calgary
Flames
over the [__] years Al McGinnis dude
he's got the hottest [__] shot in
hockey it's like [__] 200 miles an
hour
right
and let's see over in these two else who
else won
I just feel like I'm forgetting to
congrat well let's see the the the the
[__] we got a game seven don't we
between the Islanders and uh capitals
range is one
I don't know what happened with Detroit
and uh Tampa Bay but uh like I said
congratulations to everybody and that
wraps up my hockey talk
I'm [__] with you you silly sock
Frenchies you [__] [__]
you [__] [__]
almost got pushed to a game seven after
going up 3-0 and I didn't write one I
didn't talk one line of [__] because I
didn't want to jinx it all was I hoping
that you guys went down that way but
then part of me wasn't because the
Bruins did that and then the next year
we won a cup and I don't ever want you
guys to win another one but I have to
begrudgingly admit you got your best
shot in years
this year you do although I got to tell
you you very easily could have lost that
series if Ottawa pulled out two more
games because then they would have won
it 4-2 and I'll tell you when the other
team wins four games you got a really
hard time bringing that series home
um
no they were really close games and uh
Ottawa played like [__] you know they
played great it was a great series and
uh [__] crushed me to watch Montreal
win so you should be happy Montreal
fence I'm a Bruins fan and it really
hurt me that you guys won and I actually
follow you guys I have the Montreal
Canadian app on my phone it always goes
five minutes to game time get your
snacks ready oh it's so [__] awful
get your snacks ready put on your silly
sock all right get your snacks ready
gives me those chills every time I read
it but it makes me hate them more and I
love it it's part of this game it's part
of sports you gotta have that team that
you [__] hate do you know how sad I
would be of Montreal Canadians somehow
that whole franchise folded I would be
at a loss who do I hate the [__]
savings
um
so anyways uh
I think they got their best chance
I mean all the really big Powerhouse
Powerhouse Western teams have kind of
been dethroned
the LA Kings didn't make it even though
I thought they did they didn't even make
the playoffs Vancouver is a shallow what
they used to be they're out of it
St Louis looked like they were stacked
to me you know
and a bunch of [__]
goal scorers they're out of it I mean
Minnesota's in it so are the ducks the
ducks actually I think it's surprise
some people
but um they just don't have like that
like you know like last year when the
[__] Blackhawks and Kings will come
and you're like all right whoever wins
this [__] war is taking the cup you
just know it
you just knew it I'm not feeling that
and I you know
Blackhawks I know the longer you hang in
there you get a little longer in the
tooth I I do feel that the Blackhawks
are going to win it again
um
I don't know I'm gonna I'm Gonna State
the obvious it's either Blackhawks
Rangers or Canadians
way to go out on a [__] limb and then
I then I hedge my bet going but I'll
tell you the Ducks they could surprise
some people see that I basically picked
almost everybody that still left so then
I could be like dude what did I say what
did I say on the last Monday of [__]
April do that you guys want it in June I
said this [__] back in April I said it I
should be coaching a team
I'm the [__] douche that talks about
[__] like that
um
so anyways congratulations to Canadians
you know you know you know my hatred fee
really isn't to that level I do wish
that you never win one but I also find
it funny
to hate like that right okay anyways so
let me know what I have left here to
talk about before I get into the goddamn
questions I do have to get back I have
to get on the bus that's why I'm [__]
early and ride on my way over to Jackson
you better not say that [__] and Jack
you better not say that in Mississippi
Jesus Christ they made me want to go
home
um so anyways what am I going to do in
Jackson Mississippi I have no idea
um but I I am going to uh try to hang
out with some locals maybe grab a beer
with somebody
and um
then we're gonna head down to Mobile
Alabama and and I'm gonna give myself a
self-guided tour of the USS Alabama or
maybe at least that sub
and um then the tour is winding down
all we have left is Kentucky and [__]
uh Evansville and then we're on to the
Kentucky Derby
um dude you know what's hilarious is
this whole trip we've all been like
picking out what the [__] we're going to
be wearing to the derby
[__] verse he was looking at he
wanted to buy these white shoes with
this white belt like [__] herb tarlik
and I'm telling I was like dude you got
to do it you gotta dress like a complete
jerk off and get a [__] hat that's
what it is
and uh oh Billy red face here I actually
uh I learned how to tie a bow tie
you know
it's very accomplishment
um so we're [__] getting excited
about that and um
I guess the races start at 10 30 in the
morning and then they go all the way to
like the race which starts at like 6 20
or something so
experienced drinkers now all right I
need to Pace myself
so the races start at 10 30 in the
morning obviously you start with a
screwdriver
or a bloody mary I just like a
screwdriver because I feel like at least
I'm fighting off a cold while I'm
[__] kicking my liver
all right
um
anyways I'll do speaking of which you
know what he wants right after that game
we're gonna leave and then we're gonna
go watch the [__] Mayweather Pacquiao
fight
and um
I don't know I think the safe bet is to
be like oh [__] Mayweather is going
to win a decision on points so then they
have the rematch that's the safe thing
what do I want to see
I want to see somebody knock out the
other guy
it's kind of hard to root for them when
you know they're getting a concussion
and they're getting [__] brain damage
and it's also hard to root against
Mayweather because of uh his record I'd
like to see that guy get to 50-0
but uh you know it's every time you
watch like a [__] a
when they hype a prize fight
once you see a guy that you think you
don't like and then they just show his
backstory and it's like you can't be
against him
you know I saw this one on on Mayweather
and uh
you know he's showing like he was 14 he
jumped on a boat
and went to Malaysia didn't speak the
language of these other Fighters
he was like crying and stuff leaving his
family he wanted to go back and then his
best friend got killed in the ring and
then he had to go in right after him
was [__] awful man
it's [__] off so he's been through
all of that [__] right then Mayweather
comes from that Dysfunctional Family
you know what I mean I don't [__]
know
I love how they're bringing up all this
[__] that the guy did in his past
Mayweather he went to [__] jail for
it and all that type of [__] and it's
just like ESPN there's such [__]
scumbags
like why why are you bringing up his
domestic violence now because you give a
[__] about that or because you're out of
[__] to talk about
it's so [__] dumb
and then you're gonna bring that up like
you're really doing some investigating
reporting like you really give a [__]
about battered women and then you can
then you go right back to Hype in the
fight well I'll fight on the [__]
century
ah just [__] it drives me up the
goddamn wall you know what I mean
then also these [__] groups you know
that are trying to stop women from being
battered they wait to this big fight to
jump on the guy when he's promoting they
come out of the woodwork it's like does
it not matter that he battered women
when he's not training for a fight
oh [__] at this like watching somebody
campaign for president
um
it's like it's strategic when you have
to give a [__] and when you bring it up
well because if well if we give a [__]
now we're just pissing into the wind
because nobody's gonna listen we gotta
wait till this guy's promoting something
and then we strike then we say we care
um
anyways I don't [__] know I'm just
hoping it's going to be a uh it better
be a great fight I don't want to see
Mayweather just [__] you know
slipping every punch for another 12
rounds as I stare at the [__]
pay-per-view money going down the
goddamn drain I love the fact that
nobody can hit him but at some point
it's like you want to see a fight
I just want to see somebody get hit
um
all right this person wrote this [__]
book called behind uh called uh
it's coming out it's called Uh
what the [__] is it's called Clinton
cash and it's basically gonna out the
clintons of how they got their cash
which is the funniest [__] thing ever
to me it's like you could write Obama
cash Bush cash
anything but [__] Johnny Cash
you could do that about any [__]
politician out here where do they get
their cash it's all filthy
this is why I don't [__] get into
this [__] I can't I just don't
understand people who just sit around
and they blame
the problems of this country on
conservatives or they blame the problems
of this country on liberals the liberal
agenda the corporate agenda it's like
how about politicians don't make any
[__] money at all
yet they're all multi-millionaires how
about that how about they're set up to
be bribed stop with this [__]
horseshit of like you know they're a
public servant
do they did this whole thing on Senator
senators make a couple hundred grand a
year which is nothing to sneeze at and
sneeze that but like the amount of them
that are multi-multi multi-fucking
millionaires they all get heads up on
land Deals they have their own private
businesses that just go through the
[__] roof it's the biggest [__]
scam I've ever seen in my life and then
if you bring it up everybody calls you
conspiracy theorist and then they just
sit there just [__] blaming the other
party
this is adults that do that [__] so
I don't know what I I would I would
recommend reading Clinton cash and just
know that you could [__] write that
probably about every politician
even Jimmy Carter who seemed to be like
the the best at least human being
um
Jimmy Carter what I loved about that guy
was he handled the [__] hostage
situation without getting into a war
with Iran
we got everybody back
you know
the one tragedy was when we tried to
rescue him that mid-air Collision so
some American servicemen did die
all right
but it was like single digits as opposed
to what the [__] we got going on over
there now which and you're not gonna
solve it
oh
do you think you could have a war that
would make Bruins and Montreal Canadian
fans like each other
you wouldn't we're going to hate each
other hate each other back then we hate
each other now we're going to hate each
other for [__] ever and that's how it
works over there in the Middle East all
right
I don't know anyway I'm in way over my
head here I'm just gonna shut the [__]
up let's uh
do a little more advertising here then
I'll read some uh
I'm gonna read some [__] average
um some of your questions here for this
week all right
um all right I gotta get rolling here
because I gotta jump on the bus in the
next few minutes
let's read here by the way everybody
a couple of quick announcements here all
right for the Thursday afternoon Monday
Morning podcast just before Friday uh
the hashtag
um if you want your questions read is uh
is hashtag t a m m p and send it to at
the mm podcast don't send it to at Bill
Burr send it to at the mm podcast
hashtag
t-a-m-m-p uh you can tweet me articles
videos questions anything you want me to
go off on I just [__] around on
Thursdays and uh if you'd like to email
the Monday Morning podcast
um it's Bill at
themmpodcast.com all right let's get
into the questions here for the week
um
cigar trailer hey Bill
promise I'm not trying to bust your ball
uh repeat this is not an attack before
the tour started you said you weren't
going to mention the names of food
places and cool spots to visit arita
called you out on not supporting local
businesses and you Justified your
position on the Thursday afternoon
podcast just before Friday he talked
about the cool Cigar Lounge built out of
a trailer just curious if this is an
exemption or a harmless contradiction I
repeat I'm not being a dick thank you no
I actually thought about what that guy
said if you've been listening to the
podcast I actually uh
mention the name
um but also it's the reason why I
mentioned that guy was he went out of
his [__] way
and he had like a 6 000 square foot
[__] restaurant that he had to fill
this wasn't some little mom and pop
place in the corner that's been there
forever it was a brand new goddamn
business the guy totally hooked us up he
kept it open after hours and all that
stuff so I felt like I owed it to him
but I got to be honest with you as much
as I gave that guy [__] for giving me
[__] you know I'm one of those guys you
give me [__] if if you're right I'll
give your [__] back and then it rolls
around my big head for a couple of days
and then I'll come back be like all
right you're right you know I like to
think that that makes me a [__]
somewhat of an enlightened human being
if I was really enlightened in the
moment I could stop
that it would stop insulting and be like
wait wait you know what you're right
you're right
that's a big moment in your life
especially if you're an angry [__] like
me to be able to stop mid-argument
and just be like you know what you're
right
you're right I'm sorry
and then what's funny is it ends the
argument and then you also get to see
the other person like frustrated because
they want to keep yelling at you and now
they can't
you know
and then if they keep yelling then you
get to be like dude I said I said you
were right what the [__] more do you
want from me and then they're actually
the dick at that point
you know
it's a great thing to do
all right slumlord retirement bill I
keep hearing you mention becoming a
slumlord and and then retiring I'm
actually doing something very similar
but I'm not a slum Lord dude I would
never be a slum Lord I would never [__]
people over uh he said I'd buy
properties in low-income area in in all
cash fix them up refinance them and then
uh rent them out every time I have done
this I've gotten more cash out than I've
put in and the mortgage is always way
less than the rent it's unbelievable but
my thing is if you're in low income
areas they're the first ones that get
fired during a bad economy
you know
then what do you do I I could I couldn't
I could not [__] evict somebody
unless they were a complete piece of
[__] I don't know if I have the heart
for this
because I'd actually like to buy
something in a low income area fix it up
and give somebody a nice place a nice
safe [__] place to live
you know that wasn't depressing maybe
give them hope and the kids try harder
in school and they get the [__] out of
there that's what I'd like to do see I
don't have the heart for this anyway so
what I was supposed to do is just be
like yeah it looks fine
let people live in squalor have one
toilet on each floor
you know
dark moist areas bring back tuberculosis
I'll make my money like the [__]
asterisket so what I'm trying so I'm
what I'm struggling with now is if slash
when I should quit my job
I'll have enough rental income by the
end of next year to replace my job I
would love to just quit and hang out
with my kids and just live a stress-free
life but my wife has a different opinion
she thinks I should keep my six-figure
job and just keep doing this in this on
the side because we would have way more
money it's an easy office job so I see
your point but I can't get over how
amazing it would be to retire in my
early 30s and be able to spend my time
however I want what do you think I
should do what would you uh spend your
free time doing thanks go [__] yourself
dude first of all congratulations man on
absolutely crushing it and making money
work for you I know there's a lot of you
guys listen going oh diet [__] six
figures I could [__] you wouldn't
most of you unfortunately would go out
and spend six figures a year you'd go
out and buy some flashy [__] car what
does this guy do he went out and he he
made his money he reinvested it and made
it work for him
um
what I think you should do is what your
wife's saying I would I would
keep working for another 10 years and
reevaluate and take that money
that you're making over the next 10
years and keep doing what you're doing
and then you'll really be able to retire
you'll be super comfortable
um
I got to be honest with you like what
would I do if I retired in my early 30s
I would probably uh
I'd kind of be bought shitless
I would I like working I like touring I
like doing all of that like when I say
that I'll I'll exit out of this business
what I really mean is I'll be in a
position in this business where I won't
have to do anything I don't want to do I
won't have to embarrass myself I won't
have to go on Dancing With the Stars and
all of that [__] you know whatever the
[__] you do whenever you your career is
tanking
um but I think what you're doing
is [__] amazing and that's what
people need to do is you got to learn
how to make your money can either
[__] set you free or it can [__]
enslave you and I didn't know [__] about
money and I just keep reading it and
reading reading and I baby stepped my
way
into learning about it and that's how I
ended up having this [__] opinion on
bankers and what they do to people
and it's an absolute sin that they don't
teach you about money the most important
[__] thing when you're in school so
but fortunately there's libraries and
books are free there
um
that you can you can educate yourself
the greatest education other than
staying away from drugs
wearing a condom and [__] like that is
um
you got to do what you're doing man I
think that's [__] great that you're
doing it um
I would uh
I don't know if I I would lose if I went
to a low income area I would I would fix
the [__] thing up but I would do it
in a way that they wouldn't make the
other people in the area
um
too too jealous that would make them
want to go in there and Rob the people
but the guts of the [__] building I
would make sure that I did it upright
and people would not have [__] leaky
sinks in that type of [__] I'd make sure
that they were fine
uh my only concern like I said was that
they're the first ones who get [__]
hatcheted when the economy tanks because
God knows the [__] at the top they're
not going to cut off their own [__]
arm
you know
those poor people wouldn't either you
can't expect people to do that so
anyways congratulations I hope to be in
your position someday sir it's a it's a
goal of mine all right Pacquiao versus
Mayweather uh bill is this a legit fight
in your opinion do you have a dog in
this fight it's absolutely legit fight
and um
I like both of these guys and uh I'm
just hoping it's going to be a great
fight I'm sorry to give you that [__]
[__] response but if I had to pick
somebody
I just love how Mayweather talks all
that [__] he's got all those cars he
throws his money and he pisses everybody
off the [__] I I really like both of
these guys I love that Pacquiao came
from absolutely [__] nothing
um and that he sings and he [__] he
becomes a senator and all this other
[__]
um
I love both of these guys
it's going to be weird to see one of
them loose
but it better not be a [__] draw I
can tell you that all I know is I'm
gonna be [__] wearing a pink bow tie
with the matching [__]
thing in my pocket and I see a sucker
they're gonna be watching it like that
that's all I know
I'm gonna be dressed in linen
all right when I go to watch it all
right Dental Health dear Billy wisdom
teeth
um my wife thinks I have perfect teeth
and says I don't do enough to deserve
them I floss occasionally usually brush
twice a day and I've never had any
cavities I'm 42. she says it's genetics
she has to do a ton more to achieve the
same whiteness just wondering what your
thoughts are on the genetics arguments
makes sense to me look at the Brits
um you know something I don't know what
the deal is with the [__] teeth I
mean they're not as bad as everybody
makes them out to be but um there's
definitely an issue over there
a stereotype but a spot on
what at that that's a sentence a
stereotype but a spot on what at that
all right
what are your rituals
having worked in the dental office some
of those mouthwashes that both whitening
actually stain teeth according to class
action lawsuit yeah I just brushed my
teeth
in the morning in the evening and then I
floss I don't have any cavities either
um
yeah I would see that there's definitely
genetics because there's type of people
that that brush and floss and all that
and then just their teeth just they rot
out of their [__] heads I don't know
what they're doing
um
I do know that when you eat sugary stuff
uh it's not the sugar that eats away
your teeth it feeds bad bacteria in your
mouth that attack your teeth I think I
do remember that from my days working in
a dental office but my ritual is every
six months I get my teeth cleaned
um and my ritual is also if the guy says
I have a cavity I get a second opinion
that's only happened one time and I
didn't sometimes they misread X-rays and
they'll dig into a perfectly good
[__] tooth
and you got a filling and then if [__]
gets under the filling next thing you
know you need a root canal then it gets
pulled and you need a partial then you
need dentures it just goes down the
[__] Hill so if you don't have any
cavities and somebody says you have a
cavity always get a second opinion
um that's all I can tell you other than
that brush twice a day not three times
floss
um
and I don't know I use scope
or Listerine
I haven't had a problem with them
staining your [__] teeth
uh so why don't you use mouthwash first
and then brush your teeth
it's pretty easy I would stay away from
red wine
as you're drinking it you smile at
somebody you have gray teeth you look a
[__] vampire
all right fiance's gay best friend a
billy red state tourist uh I need some
advice from you and maybe Nia I
apologize if I spelled it wrong no you
didn't uh she has the time well
unfortunately I'm on the road here uh my
fiance is living with me and also
carrying my baby girl who is due in
August congratulations she's been
friends with this gay guy for a long
time she says he's the only one who can
make her laugh so hard she almost pisses
herself I'm fine that they are close and
I'm fine with him being gay I was raised
in Texas where homosexuality is isn't as
welcomed as some places especially since
I went to a Baptist Church all of my
life before you rant it was never a hate
gays kind of preaching it was more of a
homosexually is unbiblical and it's a
sin love them anyways
now you guys save yourselves in the end
anyway my perspective is people are free
to do what they want as long as they
don't oppose it on me she went to spend
a few days with her gay friend and his
boyfriend and when she came back she
told me a few stories about the fun they
had including when he had to use the
restroom so bad he went in while she was
showering
I'm not against them being friends but I
think he should have had enough respect
for me as a man to not walk into the
bathroom while my woman was in the
shower gay or not he still has a dick
and shouldn't walk into a shower another
man's woman is naked should I bring this
up or should I leave it be if I should
if I should bring it up what should I
say without hurting
her feelings keep in mind she is
pregnant and hormonal uh love you love
the show the Texan
um I would have a and I would just have
a PS my baby has a high chance of being
a redhead lots of Reds on her side and
mine including both of our mothers well
there you go you'll have a funny little
bastard oh I'm sorry you have a you have
a daughter she'll be a hot [__] then
um
all right uh what would I say I would I
would have an adult conversation with
them just say listen man I'm not trying
to be a dick
um it's not cool that's not cool for you
to be going in there
um when my wife is in there
all right
I I just and then what's what's I don't
know I don't know how you say this to
the guy
just as a man you know I don't want you
going in and going to the bathroom while
my wife is naked in the shower okay
that's it
that's it you know what I'm gay or
whatever listen I I don't care I don't
care that you're gay
you know
I I don't have any problem with you
being gay I have a problem with you
going in naked while my wife is in the
shower okay you're crossing a line there
and I I don't want you to cross that
line again okay that's it we're cool and
I would leave it at that and I wouldn't
even tell your wife about it and if you
he tells your wife
and she brings it up with you just say
listen I'm not comfortable with that I
don't want another naked man peeing
while you're in the shower I don't think
that's unreasonable
I don't think that's unreasonable and if
she gives you [__] just just be like
look can you just respect me on this
okay we had it out he agreed with me
all right I'm doing this because I love
you
all right
go put on the Real Housewives I'll sit
here with you but just you know there's
a there's a line here I think you're
totally within your rights
just in general you know what I mean
like yeah no I don't want you to do that
you have a [__] right to say that
just because you say no to somebody
who's gay does not you know does not
make you [__] homophobic they are
human beings and they're capable of
Crossing Lines he crossed the line you
don't like it it's not it has nothing to
do with him being gay he has to do with
the fact that he's a man you're treating
him like a [__] man you treat him the
way you treat a straight man there's
nothing wrong with that at least I don't
think so
um that's the money Morning podcast I'll
check in with you guys on Thursday have
a nice couple of days and hey read up on
money read up on money get your money to
[__] work for you
um I highly recommend you do not put it
in the [__] stock market I think
that's the biggest [__] scam ever I
am a big believer in buying investing in
something that you can walk up to and
touch